[Music]
today's question comes from sarah in
canada my husband and i earn about five
thousand dollars a month and we're
thirty thousand dollars in debt we've
been looking for a new rental situation
which is challenging in the current
market out of the blue one of my
husband's clients offered to let us live
in one of our homes for 500 bucks a
month my husband will still get paid
normally when doing work for her she is
a real rags to rich historian is
incredibly generous and for the first
time we don't have to be scared about
whether we can make rent or bills and
our debt will be paid off quickly my
question is this
when you've always been treading water
to keep your head just barely above it
how do you learn to kick back and float
how do you let yourself feel safe and
breathe for the first time in years
there's a lot in this question dave
um
here's my thoughts off top of my head
there is a difference between letting
yourself feel safe and breathing and
kicking back and floating ah great and
if you kick back and float
you will never feel safe and you will
never be able to breathe
and so i don't want you to ever quote
unquote kick back and float um the i
wish there was a sexier way to say this
but you got to practice you got to
practice reminding yourself you and your
husband come up with new words that you
give for each other when the other
person's starting to get amped up and
you say hey let's take a breath my wife
and i did this for years anybody healing
from trauma does this you practice it
and you call it out with each other and
over time your body adjusts to being
safe and i'll also tell you if you're
living in a special rent situation
you're not safe
you got to save up some money and get
yourself your own place because this
isn't going to be this way forever
that's my thoughts so when
we're coaching people
with their money
and they're in a highly stressed out
freaked out they're behind on their
bills their car is about to be repo'ed
they got a lot of debt
it is
it if the first
10 years i did it it caught me off guard
it would catch me off guard it no longer
does just because of experience
that when people start doing a budget
and then they use the money that they've
got and they say we've got this much
money and on this date we'll have that
fixed on that date we'll have that fixed
on that date we'll have that debt paid
off on that date we'll be debt free on
that day we'll have our emergency fund
based on projecting the budget that's in
front of me and they do their budget for
the first time and they're able to
extrapolate their future
none of the work is done
their situation has not changed
only their
ability to see their way out of their
situation with a system
has changed
that is where you can breathe and feel
safe and their stress level goes down 90
percent
just by laying out the freaking plan
there's some research that says people
with the moment you make your first
counseling appointment you start to feel
better well and people cancel their
counseling appointment because they feel
better yeah they feel better like they
they have a big fight book a marriage
counseling appointment and then they
make up then they don't get the help
they need and then they don't get the
help and they cancel the appointment
happens all the time the same thing
happens when you do a budget even though
you still have your bills are out there
screwed up
everything's still up in the air it's
still a mess
but now you can see how you're going to
get out the stress level drops 90
percent and that's when you can breathe
and feel safe so you need to project
this
temporary rent situation that you have
out
and say we're going to be out of debt
here and we're going to move out of this
voluntarily before the generosity of the
runs out sweet lady runs out and she you
change your narrative about the way you
look at her because suddenly she
actually wants to collect rent
and so um and all that's different than
kicking back and floating yeah you feel
safe because of your plan you breathe
because of your plan because you can we
we have a thing we're doing here we're
working the baby steps we're on a budget
we can see the progress we can see a
future that is bright there's a vision
for our life and your stress level goes
down and you breathe and feel safe but
you're not kicking back and floating
you're you're busting it with a great
intensity that's right
so yeah i agree with you to separate
those two statements and
i i think you're wanting
something you should probably never get
which is to do nothing don't ever
don't ever want to strive to do nothing
yeah resting is not nothing there's no
joy in it there's no joy
you got to rest and rest isn't that's
not what we're saying and you got to
sleep it's not what we're saying those
are critical parts to being well but you
got to be intentional about rest you got
to be intentional about sleep you feel
safe and breathe while you're getting
crap done absolutely that's that's how
you feel safe is having purpose and
working towards something that's a good
point
that's a good point there's a there's
this empty nothingness
thing you mean you these uh chambers
that they've got at these things now
where you can go float oh yeah and all
this stuff yeah i'd say that that is not
i mean it's fine to do and i'm not mad
at her it's nothing like that it's a way
of life but you don't want your life to
be that oh you want your life to be i'm
climbing a mountain and me and my wife
is i'm going on a hike me and pat
lincoln are talking about that our whole
culture's set up for that
to the goal we work to do nothing to do
nothing to get to the end of the day and
sit in your recliner and kick it back so
you can do nothing no what it lame
people die right after they retire